to give you a
you know sort of a brief overview there
are four
structural proteins these are the
proteins that made up
a structure of the virus
so spike has protein that acts as a
trimer
so it needs three copies
e envelope protein that acts as a
pantomere
so it needs five copies to act properly
m is a is a membrane protein
and it forms dimers and actually it
forms beautiful lattice and this is
something that we've been studying and
we are seeing it in simulations
it it actually forms a very nice grit or
you know
threats uh you know uh of of different
dimers
attached next to each other there's a
bunch of copies of each other and they
naturally when you have a bunch of
copies of each other they form an
interesting lattice
exactly and and you know if you think
about this
right so so so the this complex
you know the divide the viral shape
needs to be
organized somehow self-organized somehow
right
so it you know if it was a completely
random process
you know you probably wouldn't have the
the the envelope shell
of the ellipsoid shape you know you
would have something you know
pretty random right shape so there is
some
you know regularity and how this uh
you know uh how these uh
m dimers get to attach to each other in
a very specific directed way is that
understandable
uh it's not understood we are now
we we've been working in the past six
months since you know
we met actually this is where where we
started working on trying to understand
the overall
structure of the envelope and the the
key components
that made up this uh you know uh
structure does the envelope also have
the virus structure
no so so the envelope is essentially is
the outer shell
of the viral particle the n the
nucleocapsid protein
is something that is inside but
get that the n is likely to interact
with m
does it go m and e like where's the e
and
so so e those different proteins
they occur in different copies on the
viral particle so so e this pantomimer
complex
we only have two or three maybe
per each particle okay we have
thousand or so of m dimers
that essentially made up uh that makes
up uh
the entire you know outer shell so most
of the outer shell is the m-dimer
when you say particle that's the viron
the virus
the individual single single element of
the virus
single virus single virus right and we
have about
you know roughly 50 to 90 spike trimers
right so so so when you you know when
you show a per
per virus particle per wireless particle
sorry what did you say 50 to 90
50 to 90 right so so this is how
this thing is organized and so now
typically right so you see this uh the
the antibodies that target you know
spike proteins certain parts of the
spike protein
but there could be some or also some
treatments right so so these are
you know these are small molecules that
bind strategic parts of these
proteins disrupting its functioning
so one of the promising directions
uh it's one of the newest directions is
actually targeting
the m dimer of the protein
targeting the proteins that make up this
outer shell
because if you're able to destroy the
outer shell
you are essentially destroying the the
the viral particle itself
so preventing it from from you know
functioning
at all so that's you think is uh
from a sort of cyber security
perspective virus security perspective
that's the best attack vector
is uh or like that's a promising attack
vector
i would say yeah so i mean this is still
tons of research needs to be
you know to be done but uh yes i think
you know so
there's more attack surface i guess more
attack surface but you know from from
our analysis from other evolution
analysis this protein
is evolutionary more stable compared to
the
say to the spike protein unstable
means a more uh static target well yes
so it it it doesn't change it doesn't
evolve
from the evolutionary perspective so
drastically
as for example the spike protein
you